ça m'est cher mais qui feraient
n'importe quoi pour toi je montrais même
les vrais sites web étaient montrées
l'everest
deal de merde
[Musique]
sérieusement on s'arrête là qu'est ce
que c'est dans cette galère
quelle fut leur dossier à mes ballons ça
s'oublie
nadia s'était dit qu'il ferait n'importe
quoi pour toi bah ça y est je crois que
suis vraiment en train de faire
n'importe quoi
[Musique]
bienvenue en seine saint denis au pays
du béton et du chômage en exclusivité le
premier habitant du 9-3 à gravir
l'himalaya je vais marcher pendant un
mois c'est la seule idée que tu ailles
dans la vessie je veux dire je vais
marcher moi j'ai pas partir avec des
bonbons - depuis quand une dispute avec
la mère
j'aimerais poser la question que tout le
monde se pose pourquoi tu fais ça à dire
ça me joue un mec est sûre je ferais
n'importe quoi pour toi je montre me
lèverai sifaoui tu montres l'everest
d'hilton merde
je vois sur ton selecta fait le mont
blanc ah mais c'est quand même palette
de montblanc déconne quoi at il mis la
paix avec sa soeur matin l'enfant créé
ce biais ah ouais en plus il faisait
beau et kilimandjaro pour l'achat score
un peu toutes les faces
[Musique]
mon boulot c'est de vous emmener au
sérieux jamais on s'arrête là si on
attend encore 50 ans il y aura peut-être
un téléphérique pour aller jusqu'aux ça
va je plaisante
matt et moi c'est toute la journée il
porte comme ça
je tiens quand ils carburent cela c'est
pas possible un frigo les gars se monte
à gagner combien pour monter sa cote
mais tu vois d'abord combien tu sais
même pas de bruit john la courneuve
c'est quoi cette galère n'avez-vous pas
perdu pour offrir ou quoi là moi
j'habite au 6ème étage à 4,11 à sa soeur
il n'y a pas un mec qui montrait pour
enjeu la chasse ça m'étonnerait il est
déjà parti
as tu déconnes
mais qu'est-ce que dans cette galère
j'espère que tu es fier de toi au crac
il ya des deux partis là bas
nadia c'est moi je t'ai dit que je
ferais n'importe quoi pour toi
bah ça y est je crois que suis vraiment
en train de faire n'importe quoi à l'eau
aux aveux
j en profite pour passer un petit coucou
à ma famille mes parents mes frères et
soeurs
il n'a dit un surtout
et puis un gros big up à tous ceux qui
me soutiennent au quercy ailleurs
mais séoul est vrai ce qu'en fait
normalement c'est vers l'est ever est
dieudonné a maintenant non sensibles
les semaines passent et ça me saoulait
leur avis sur ce qui va se faire un
bonbon qui dit pas tes potes qui s'est
donné un très bon sens nous avons tous
nos collègues au cur salut yak
[Musique]